david authorities are able to clear the
ambassador bridge uh this weekend uh
what is the latest there in windsor
yeah so the the the bridge is open and
that's so important because so much uh
goods that is relied upon by factories
on both sides of the border comes over
that bridge it's open this morning the
cbsa the border services people
reporting no delays for commercial
traffic windsor police are telling
people you've got to approach the bridge
in some different ways so if you're
anywhere in that area there is going to
be some traffic realignment and in fact
canada border service is reporting no
delay in commercial traffic at every
border crossing across the country
except two and that's in kutz alberta
where the border remains blockaded and
in emerson manitoba again the border
blockaded by protesters the one in
surrey bc the pacific highway there had
been police action there over the
weekend but that has been cleared as
well so that too commercial traffic
getting through there that's great uh
that the blockades uh are lifted at the
ambassador bridge and in surrey behind
me though here in ottawa the occupation
continues bitterly cold morning minus 24
right now not many people on the streets
but still a lot of vehicles parked as
they have been now for three weeks and
counting
i was going to ask you about that wasn't
a deal reached with the protesters over
the weekend
yeah it's a bit a bit controversial
mayor jim watson the mayor of ottawa
reached out to one of the protest
organizers tamara leach and uh and they
apparently reached some sort of deal to
withdraw some of the vehicles only from
residential neighborhoods behind me is
part of a hill not a residential
neighborhood so presumably the idea
would be to bring in some of these
trucks from where residents have been
complaining about honking horns and
violation i should point out of a court
order and just delinquent behavior
rowdy-ism people cannot sleep bringing
those trucks in we'll see we're not sure
what sort of command and control these
protest organizers have over some of the
participants and as i say a lot of
people jumping on the mayor saying you
shouldn't or you should not be
negotiating with these folks you should
be telling the police to arrest and
remove
again some of these protesters have been
calling for the overthrow of the federal
government
are those the kind of people you want to
negotiate with or have any basis to
nonetheless that's out there this
morning we'll see if it makes a
difference
all right and finally david do we
understand the prime minister justin
trudeau he is a meeting with the
premiers today because now that the
bridge in windsor has been reopened you
know the focus uh seems to be back on
ottawa on the nation's capital
in ottawa but don't forget coots that's
an important border crossing and as is
emerson so the premiers are going to get
together with the prime minister they're
going to talk about the blockades one of
the issues on the table is does ottawa
invoke the federal emergencies act it
never did so during the pandemic why
because the emergencies act is usually
only invoked at the invitation or the
support of premiers when a province says
it's out of my hands i need the federal
government to do something so there'll
be that discussion today and we'll see
where that goes there's also a very rare
meeting of the federal liberal caucus to
discuss about these blockades later
today a vote on a conservative motion
calling on the government
to publish a roadmap on how and when
vaccine mandates will end and to publish
that roadmap by the end of the month and
if that vote goes through and the
government says fine we'll we'll come up
with something by the end of the month
maybe that lowers a temperature too and
contributes to the removal of these
protesters
all right david aiken and ottawa the
very latest thank you